you
hi everyone it's Jerry this another
group of five puzzles each of them it's
white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best play for white ok the
solution to puzzle 1 is to first capture
on d7 rook takes Queen is an only move
Knight c7 deflecting the rook away from
d8 rook takes is yet again an only move
and now rook to d8 is checkmate this is
a checkmate in three puzzle and one that
can maybe be best found by recognizing
this particular pattern this particular
shape and the bishop and rook converging
on the d8 square the king from the
initial position has no legal moves and
so if you can push through in some way
getting a heavy piece to d8 that will be
me moving on to the second white to play
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation ok the solution
puzzled2 is to first capture the rook
and the idea behind this is that white
wants to be able to make use of this
diagonal oftentimes a bishop on this
diagonal in conjunction with the knight
ng5 is quite strong and in many cases
will be picking up material sometimes
even leading to some discovered checks
well if a queen is allowed to get to
that diagonal let's say after the bishop
takes or pawn takes now comes Queen to
d5 and in some cases it could lead to a
smothered mate however in this case
we're not quite having that but we're
certainly having the win of a
significant amount of material after
rook to h8 so if black is aware of the
strengths of Queen to d5 maybe now they
take with the Queen but now comes a
checkmate in four starting first with
rook 2h a king takes is an only move
Queen check only move Queen check only
move checkmate to be perfectly honest
this puzzle is one that I did not softly
I did get to this point right here rip
to H a and after the capture I went in
for the not best Fork of the Queen and
King I went for that but of course we
could be doing much better
going forward with checkmate if there's
one main thing I want to highlight
recognize the strength of this night on
the g5 square against an opposing king
the black King on g8 not only in
conjunction with the bishop along this
diagonal or a queen but keep in mind
what it is also doing it's watching over
these potential flight squares by that
black King and sure enough it is
highlighted in a great way in this
particular puzzle with this final
position the knight contributing
watching over h7 moving on to the third
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best play okay the solution
this one is to first give check King f7
another check King takes Queen h8 these
were all only moves by black and finally
you have the Queen white is that
material and simply winning now how can
you come up with this particular
sequence of moves well the first thing
you might think about is just grabbing
the Queen but seeing a bit further
you'll see that that you lose the Queen
right back so how can you work around
this well how can you in other words get
out of this pin because if it is not
present then you're just going to be
winning the black Queen for free well
how can you move the Queen and give
check well from this current position
you can well you can in a few moves
however after a couple checks after this
first check there's still not a good
Queen move to give check only after rook
to f8 will there be a successful way to
get out of the pin and then grab the
Queen successfully without losing your
own moving on to the fourth white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best play okay solution of puzzle
for is Bishop h6 pretty neat move to be
seeing the Queen can be captured in a
couple ways both Queen's in jeopardy at
this point but the main idea is one
that's maybe a bit familiar too if you
look back on puzzle one of this group of
five puzzles
the bishop and the rook are converging
on this f8 square that little triangle
of peace is focusing on the f8 point
capturing the Queen that's going to be
made on f8 same story it doesn't defend
against f8 the best move is to maybe
drop the rook back but bond takes Queen
black is busted moving on to the fifth
and final wait to play pause the video
see if we can find the best continuation
ok the solution to this one is Queen to
g3 and keep in mind the rook is
currently pinned maybe quite tempting to
do this and it's a quite strong threat
is it not
if this rook can move that will turn out
to be discovered check and mate so Queen
to g3 has this in mind because if she
has taken rook takes Bishop game over so
what's something more that black can be
doing after Queen to g3 Queen takes pawn
and now after Queen to h3 if the Queen
is captured there's maybe some checks
that could be thrown in however after
they have been exhausted this threat of
not only grabbing the bishop but simply
delivering checkmate there's no good
solution to it white at the very least
we'll be picking up the bishop and one
last variation is after the Queen blocks
on h3 what do you do after Queen to d6
placing the RIP back into a pin well now
here comes King - h1 simply getting out
of the pin a quiet move and there is now
no successful defense against the rook
capturing the bishop or delivering
checkmate due to the double check so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it and be
sure to let me know how you did in the
comments section below take care bye
you